one is the most experienced
specialized and qualified operators that
the joint special operations command has
to offer
the other is the united states last line
of defense when all other agencies and
defensive options have failed
so what would happen if a division agent
and a ghost were pitched against each
other
and who would come out on top
[Music]
division agents shouldn't be compared to
an elite military unit in the
traditional sense
when military units are trained for
specific tasks and missions
the division agents are a civilian
agency whose members lay dormant until
activated
the ideal division agent is loyal adept
versatile
and in good physical condition their
quick thinking
ability to make tough decisions when
needed and highly sought after
problem-solving skills
are just some of what the agency is
looking for when recruiting a new agent
it is beneficial for candidates to have
a background in community or enforcement
areas
for example healthcare the military law
enforcement
and rescue services but this certainly
isn't a requirement
agents of the division are required to
be able to execute a wide range of tasks
as hidden agents among society they are
often activated with very little
knowledge of what's happening behind the
scenes
so they must be creative versatile
independent
and capable of operating outside the
standard rules of engagement
however once activated and then deployed
a division agent outranks all other
tactical units in the field
this authority allows agents to bypass
laws regulations
and jurisdictional boundaries as needed
they can freely organize local assets
whether it be civilian or military to
help address local needs
and due to the secretive nature of the
role most training is disguised
and worked into the recruits daily life
examples of this training is exclusive
black belt only training classes
at neighborhood martial arts studios
high intensity workouts at local cross
training gyms
with special instructors who happen to
also be division trainers
advanced firearm classes or technology
courses at local community colleges
again all taught by division experts and
attended by other recruits or active
agents
division agents are expected to maintain
this year-round training for the entire
duration of their service
basic survival skills combat and
intelligence training
is also required to be honed through
regular practice and exercises
the general consensus is that agents are
devoting all spare time
to training and preparation
this group for specialized tactics also
known as the ghosts
is a highly classified elite special
mission unit within the u.s army and
joint special operations command
it is the army's special missions unit
whose members are armed with the state
of the art weapon systems
and are trained in the best field and
combat tactics
they're the most experienced specialised
and qualified special
operations force that the joint special
operations command has to offer
their tactics involve striking enemies
at their most vulnerable
swiftly silently and without being seen
hence the name ghosts
ghost recon teams specialise in covert
operations in politically sensitive
territory with little to no support
typical missions include assassination
or kidnapping of high value targets
to secure or destroy sensitive documents
and classified hardware
and the sabotaging or harassment of key
enemy forces
only the most elite operators are
invited to become ghosts
having already proven themselves in
combat during previous deployments
while all ghosts serve with a strong
sense of honour and duty they understand
that their success will never be
publicly acknowledged by politicians
or public broadcast selection of
potential ghosts is from various
branches of the us military
and they go through a selection phase
which involves a grueling physical
and mental test
although from similar timelines they're
very clearly from different tom clancy
universes
not just because the developers have
said so but also when thinking about
their specific functions
they wouldn't be active at the same time
the division takes place during
and after the collapse of the united
states as well as the rest of the world
they're the last line of defense and are
only activated when all other means have
failed
so in theory the ghosts have already
stood down or been killed in their world
let's assume that the agents and the
ghosts were thrown into an arena
and pit up against each other in a
face-to-face fight
due to the division tech being
considerably more offense orientated i'd
have to say that the agents would come
out on top
but this wouldn't be fair because this
certainly isn't what the ghosts are
intended for
if the two groups were put in a
situation where they had to hunt each
other down
it would be a different story their
training and equipment all focuses on
the ghosts being able to move in
execute and move out without being
noticed
the agents wouldn't see them coming and
they would likely be taken out before
firing a single shot
of course location would be a factor too
the division agents are plucked from
society
tested trained and then put back into
their respective neighborhoods
where they are expected to continue
training for their potential activation
a large part of their preparation is
getting familiar with the environment
where all the vantage points are areas
to avoid getting locked down
and potential safe houses their
activation has them helping their own
communities
where they are in their element while
they both have cutting edge advanced
technology and equipment at their
disposal
they are built for completely different
means
division agents are chosen from all
aspects of life although a lot of come
from the military
not all of them have they're regular
people with normal jobs
they could be first responders like
firefighters police
emts they could even be teachers or
professional poker players
and while they have some pretty advanced
training under the best of instructors
for the entirety of their service
they're still out there spending the
majority of their time living a normal
life
whereas the ghosts are the best of the
best
pulled from us army special operations
they are elite spec
ops using the best experimental
classified weapons and tech
this is their day job and have clocked
in far more hours of combat time
fighting a range of different enemies in
different environments
regarding their training and experience
the ghosts are on a completely different
level
however the ghosts work and function as
a team and although there has been a few
examples of situations where ghosts have
been forced to work solo
according to the law both in-game and
the books the ghosts work in a squad of
four
where each member has a role
complementing the next
it isn't that they are incapable of
working alone more that the ghost's true
strength comes from the squad
configuration and training
as a single entity while the division
agents are activated as a cell of four
agents
they are trained to work completely
autonomously as a solo operative
obviously there is considerable increase
in safety with numbers
but their overall effectiveness doesn't
change while running solo
and as we've seen in both games and the
supporting novels this is more often the
case than not
so although a team of ghosts would
likely be far more effective than a team
of agents
it would come down to the points raised
earlier as to whether this would still
be the situation when comparing in a
one-on-one scenario
there is no clear black and white answer
to the question of which one is better
they both have entirely different
functions when active in the field
one has the best spec ops training and
equipment available and excel in using
the element of surprise
to capture or eliminate targets without
anyone knowing they were there
the other is trained to be the last line
of defense to save what remains
they are meant to be seen to support and
rebuild the communities they live in
yet they are alone and must be prepared
for the worst to happen
at any moment
there are situations that could play out
that would see either side of this
fictional battle
coming out on top but if i had to pick
which one would be better
i'd have to say that the division
agent's area of expertise is far too
specific to location
and situation and that the ghosts arena
would be considerably more flexible
given their training and experience
however i think many of you would agree
there is another type of operative
within the clancy universe not discussed
here
who if it came down to it would not only
outdo each of these agencies
but probably wouldn't even break a sweat
if they combined their forces
nomad glad you haven't gone soft since
olivia
let's go we need to talk
anyway i hope you've enjoyed this weird
little crossover speculation video
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]